welcome back to cbs mornings we'll have
our talk of the table segment a bit
later than usual in just a few minutes
but we now turn to the growing baby
formula shortage across the country
according to retail analyst date
assembly the nationwide out-of-stock
rate for baby formula hit 43 percent
this month we're joined now by food and
drug administration commissioner dr
robert califf dr caleb good morning good
to see you
good morning i'm glad i can be with you
this morning
so dr kale if this kind of shortage
doesn't happen overnight why didn't the
fda take steps much earlier to prevent
it from from getting this bad
well first of all let me say that we're
very aware of the issues this raises for
families
i'm the grandfather of six children and
raised three myself so i know how
basic and fundamental the nutritional
needs of children are and how worrisome
it is for this is for parents
we've been working with this
really since complaints came in
about a particular plant
that had problems
and as we tried to manage both dealing
with making sure the plant is safe
because it makes some really essential
components of infant formula and then
also trying to keep up with what's
happening in the market by
helping
other companies fill in the gaps so this
has been a work in progress all along
so so when do you expect the shortage
will be over what can you tell parents
who are looking for a timeline
well
we would expect this to gradually get
better over the next several weeks and
within
really several months to
be completely up to normal but i'd
stress that
up to normal means 100 of normal and as
long as we're in a reasonable range it
should be entirely possible for families
to get their formula increasingly
really over the next several days to
weeks what do you say to the families
though dr caleb said you know we don't
have several days or several weeks that
this is really a dire emergency
situation i know you're aware of that
you certainly pointed out in your own
family you recognize that this is an
issue but families say we don't have the
time we need it now we need it yesterday
well
i would stress that this
degree of stocking of the shelves our
numbers look a little bit different than
the number that you quoted
so we believe it is possible for all
families to get formula there is enough
to go around but it's not distributed in
the right way so
i want to fully recognize that it's very
difficult and
recognize people's concerns
there's a website you can go to
hhs.gov
formula
which gives hotlines for all the
manufacturers and a way to get access to
formula if you're having trouble you
know yesterday on face the nation former
fda commissioner that would be scott
gottlieb said something that had a lot
of people shaking their heads their
mouths dropped where he said basically
there are only nine people in this
country nine was the number he named
that oversee the baby formula industry
how is that possible
we'll be addressing that in uh budget
hearings with the house this week
actually
i would say the food side of the fda has
been
in need of more financial resources so
that we can hire enough people for quite
some time
so it's a major emphasis of mine to get
this budget increased so that we have
adequate staff i do want to note that
the nine people have been working night
and day
in fact over the entire weekend we had
multiple groups of staff pitching in
to
deal with this shortage
dr caleb if parents struggle to find
formula here in the u.s should they be
able to buy it from europe
oh we uh over the weekend one of the
things that we worked on continuously
was
putting forth a set of rules that would
enable
the use of formula that was intended for
other countries
some of it even manufactured in the us
intended for other countries
you can imagine that it's really
important that we make sure that the um
constituents remembering that formula
has over 30 different constituents that
have to be in the formula
and also that the instructions for use
are in english
are a language that the consumer can
understand because mixing up the formula
getting the right formula for the infant
is critical
but as soon as today we should uh be
able to announce our path
forward for this
a lot of parents will be waiting uh for
information related to that news dr
caleb thank you very much
thank you